parece un edificio común y corriente en
el corazón del barrio chino de bajo
Manhattan Pero dentro de él operaba una
estación de policía china no declarada
según denunciaron las autoridades
estadounidenses al fiscal de Brooklyn
comentó que en uno de los pisos se
brindaban servicios gubernamentales sin
autorización de Estados Unidos la
acusación más severa indica que este
edificio era utilizado por el Ministerio
de Seguridad Pública para operar contra
compatriotas críticos del gobierno de
shipping un hecho por el que fueron
detenidos dos ciudadanos de origen chino
las denuncias acusan a estos oficiales
del Ministerio de seguridad pública de
participar en esquemas de represión
transnacional dirigidos a miembros de la
comunidad de la diáspora china en la
ciudad de Nueva York y en otras partes
del país
los acusados fueron identificados como
lucian One y Chen Pin Pin Quienes fueron
arrestados bajo los cargos de
Conspiración y obstrucción a la justicia
por eliminar presuntos contactos
telefónicos con el Ministerio de
seguridad público chino
Además este lunes el FBI oficializó las
denuncias contra una treintena de
funcionarios chinos por montar una
granja de trolls en redes sociales para
agredir a opositores y críticos del
gobierno de jin el director del FBI
repudio el accionar de los acusados
todas estas personas son agentes que
apoyan la campaña del gobierno chino
para exportar la represión y socavar el
estado de derecho en todo el mundo
incluso aquí mismo en Estados Unidos
dentro de los apuntados se encuentran
ocho personas que están prófugas y que
están involucradas en una causa de 2020
sobre intervención de reuniones de video
remotas que conmemoraban la masacre
detienen de 1989